This is Jeff Negan and you're watching now you see it
Let's talk about how the film inglourious basterds is actually making fun of you
Quentin [Tarantino] is one of the most popular and consistently violent mainstream directors his films focus on people committing violence
criminals who killed contract killers a black-market gun Runner who kills a former assassin killing for revenge [a] special [world] [War] [2] unit whose [1]
Goal is "killing Nazis". More contract killers and finally his newest film the hateful eight coming out fall 2015 will star Samuel Jackson as you
Guessed it as contract killer
There's no doubt that Tarantino's films, especially [his] higher budget ones display a sort of hyper violence with numerous and exaggerated deaths
Vanity Fair made a nice chart tallying each death in a Tarantino film and how that person died?
showing just how violent his films can be tarantino's eighth film inglourious basterds is no exception the film leads 57 kills not including the
342 Deaths from the Fire and the Fear at the end of the film
This averages to one gruesome death about every two [and] a half minutes now. That's vile
Even with all this violence inglourious basterds was a huge financial and critical success earning over 300 million dollars in Eight Academy award nominations
the majority of Tarantino's films did well in the box office in fact of the nine films Tarantino has directed eight have earned triple their
original budget
So what does this say about us the viewers who pay to see and enjoy Tarantino's films?
Do we like violence is it wrong for us to enjoy movies where people [die] left and right?
Tarantino realizes this juxtaposition and even goes so far as to criticize us the viewers for finding hyper violence in his film so entertaining
Let's take a look at inglorious bastards and see how he critiques an audience that glamorizes violence
Inglorious basterds is about a World War II special unit named the basterds whose mission is to blow up a cinema worth dozens of High-ranking
Nazi Soldiers in the Lead Watch a Propaganda film
Including Hitler himself the film shown at the cinema is about Friedrich [solar] a Nazi soldier who single-handedly kills?
215 Russians from a guard Tower the film titled Nation's pride is extremely violent
From what we see the film consists of little more than shots of [Friedrich] [solar] shooting and killing dozens of Russian Soldiers
The crowd of Nazis loves it they cheer and laugh at each death praising
Hitler even tells the director of the film this is your best film yet
We can't help but look at the audience watching a she's cried and find them a bit humorous and ridiculous
They view this repetitive tasteless and unnecessary killing entertaining and well made to us it appears to be nothing but a cheap spectacle movie
But think about it doesn't it sound familiar the Nazi viewers our audience members watching a film, but so are we watching employers bastards
It's a film within a film don't we react with similar phrase to Quentin Tarantino's [hyper-violent] films when were the audience members
I want to suggest to the Tarantino is trying to say us viewing inglourious basterds is similar to the Nazis view a nation's pride
We cheer at death even when it's tasteless and glorifies unnecessary violence
we see just as much excessive violence in inglourious basterds [as] the nazis do a nation's product while the bastards are in the middle of
their plan to blow up the building [the] owners of the cinema in a separate attack light the whole cinema on fire and lock the
Exit doors, so the Nazi crowd is trapped and burned alive
Even though the bathrooms mission to kill everyone in the cinema is fulfilled they still shoot into the crowd [of] Nazis more unnecessary
violence and blow up the cinema even more unnecessary violence
There's ridiculous violence throughout the film people call off scalps get beat to death with baseball bats and get shot in the testicles
both nations pride an inglorious basterds contain excessive violence similarities don't stop
[they're] both
Protagonists carved Nazi symbols with a knife and are overly faithful to their country even the shots in Nation's pride and inglorious basterds are similar
Look at the shot of a person flying out of the exploding cinema notice the similarities between this shot and these shots of soldiers falling
out of buildings during nations pride
Tarantino is showing that his movie is not far off from Nations pride
Even the film titles are comparable
Where inglorious basterds is the exact opposite meaning of nations pride these films are similar and so are their respective audiences us viewing [inglourious] [basterds]
And the Nazis viewing nations [prime], we both praised the violence in the film. We both cheer on death
We both get desensitized to the brutality of killing by comparing us to the Nazi viewers Tarantino is criticizing our love for excessive violence
We're a bunch of easy to please
Dim-witted audience members who find entertainment and senseless gruesome killing in the same way that the Nazi viewers are portrayed as simple-Minded audience members find
Entertainment in the over to top violence in Nations [pride]. He's poking fun at us
He's saying or as ridiculous as the nazi viewers are look other instances of observed violence
And this is by no means limited to include his bastards either Tarantino does this in all of his other films as well
He sometimes even uses death for Comedy I
Said Til Miss [Lora] [good]. [bye]
Bye, Miss Lora you gotta have an opinion. I mean do you think that God came down from Heaven and Stopped oh?
Man, I shot Marvin in the face fuck to do that. I didn't mean to do it was an accident
It takes [skill] to pawn audience into a world where killing can make up a punchline
[but] there's more to it than that [the] screen desensitizes us
We can remove ourselves from the realities of death when we watch a film and Tarantino knows the extent
We can see a death is a joke though is worth making fun of and Nation's pride provides a good allegory for how ridiculous
We can be is it hypocritical?
That we can praise violence in a film yet denounce it in reality one final anecdote [about] the two films and their audiences while Nation's
Pride is playing shows on Ax kills the real Friedrich soler
but nobody in the audience
notices because they're so engrossed in the violence of the film they think the gunshot noise is just another sound effect is Tarantino making a
Commentary about how we don't address or notice deaths in reality and only pay [attention] to the ones in the movies we adore
[Glory] [spouses] is not the only film to Critique its viewers with any film that features an audience consider if the directors making a commentary
About the audience actually watching the film willful wall street is about the rise and fall [of] a corrupt businessman named Jordan Belfort
He's unfaithful to his wife steals money from thousands of people has known who truly loves him and spends years in Jail
Logically, we should look at Jordan Belfort as a dishonest despicable man
But look at the audience in the final shot of the film do they look like they despise him
They adore him they want to be just like him rich and famous no matter how much
dishonesty and stealing it takes just like inglorious basterds the director is showing the flaws of us as an audience is Jordan Belfort really the
type of person we should strive to be [like] a clever director can use audiences or even crowds of people as a way of
generalizing a society as a whole
It's most interesting however when the commentary is centered on the viewers of the film who are far from [perfect]
So the next time you see any movie that features an audience ask yourself are they making fun of me?
*trumpets playing*
*applause*